oh
look
yeah
yeah yeah i saw that
you feel it
you're kicking
what's up guys i don't know if it's just
me but this year in particular i've been
feeling way more festive than i've ever
felt in my entire life like i just
ordered some christmas lights we're
definitely gonna deck out the house this
year we've already done up the living
room and i definitely took thanksgiving
way more seriously than i ever did
before hence i didn't actually vlog most
of the cooking that took place in this
house but with that said thanksgiving
was awesome for us i hope you guys out
there also had a great thanksgiving i
think for me it's maybe because the
baby's coming that i've actually
re-engaged with the holiday season
because growing up as a kid we love the
holidays it's the time of year when we
don't have school we get presents mom
cooks and there's like movie specials on
tv 24 7. but somewhere along the way you
grow up and you move out because you're
living on your own mom's not there to
cook all the wonderful foods for you and
you don't necessarily take the time off
from work as much as you would have
taken from school and more than likely
as an adult i'm just way too busy to
even care about all the festivities so
why this year i think it's the baby i
think with tiff being pregnant now and
we're expecting the baby coming in
february that familial
instinct in me that you know creating
this familial bond has started starting
to re-engage and i'm looking forward to
the holidays i'm looking forward to
creating traditions and i think for the
past 10 years you know with tiff and us
being together as a family we haven't
really taken part in any sort of
tradition making we haven't started
anything where we're like all right
every year we're doing this or you know
what as a family we're always gonna do
that but yeah this year something's
changing and even tips changing one she
started cooking which is a miracle in
its own right but anyways this video is
about recapping our thanksgiving week
hi everyone hi
guys
how are you good
good are you gonna meet your grand baby
yeah there that's your b your grand
[Music]
baby's not bothered
actually this baby is lower than isaac
so chan clan comes into town they meet
tiff as a pregnant mom for the very
first time and it was very very sweet
why this girl and then pointy as a boy
what do you think
is that a scientific
no it's a 50 50. it's a chance i cannot
tell you
do you think it's like do you think my
belly's going more sideways or more
front oh fine i guess they keep calling
you dietopal oh what does that mean yeah
i don't mean people's praying pregnancy
yeah not sure that's always pregnant but
it literally translates to big stomachs
but usually you just use it for like
this game wasn't about pregnant women
tiff and my mom had like a little
bonding time too with the baby where
they were just kind of like feeling the
baby kick
come on baby cake hello
hi this is your grandma it's a chinese
grandma
[Music]
your mama
mama mama i am your mama i know mama
i thought it was really really sweet to
be able to see the generations all in
one shot with the baby and then tiff and
then my mom all kind of creating this
moment this beautiful moment together
[Music]
i wanted to buy stuff for the baby
while we were traveling i want to buy
things from here and there
but so we wait we got the big stuff
first the furniture yeah all the stuff
like clothing i think
we wait until the baby's here yeah when
they get to like two
three years old that's the time i really
want to like dress them up that's true
they could work more often
so spending quality time with family
check what about good food well my
family decided to go on a very very
special food hunt we wanted to spend a
little more trying something that we
don't normally get to eat one of the
first things that popped up for us was
omakase kaiseki omakase meaning you
trust in the chef to serve whatever they
want to serve you and kaiseki meaning
little dishes so it's basically like an
omakase japanese tapas
[Music]
we are eating omakase for to celebrate
carrie's 28th birthday and it's crazy
because i met him when he was 18.
so this is the year that
10 year 10 years now 10 years for us
knowing you yeah true my baby that means
we've been together for ten years it's
coming up man may this is this upcoming
may
the baby's gonna join us for a tenure uh
cod sperm i was trying to get it and
then well that was better when i was
falling apart
creamy creamy huh
[Music]
that's crazy good yeah then by the way
isaac is not eating what we're eating
and i'm going to be eating fully cooked
items because i'm pregnant but isaac
he's going to be getting the chicken
because this meal is way too adventurous
for him
yeah you're the most
out of everyone
[Music]
oh okay thank you oh yay tiff is
pregnant so she can't be eating anything
raw so we requested her food to be
cooked so they actually cooked this one
yeah and i guess everything else is
safe to eat yes
that's good that's good what do i eat
first i'm gonna start this side first is
it a one bite thing so i'm gonna get
everything and i want to go here we
[Music]
all right i go the snail it looks
no if you're not an adventurous person
this is gnarly looking i'm gonna drink
it first
[Music]
texture is awesome
very crispy it's like chewy and crispy
and soft and tender at all at the same
time
so you got the cooked version of the
macaroni
even the cook's other thing i know i
actually am kind of jealous because i'm
like i kind of want to try the quick
ones too that's probably really good
yeah i have a fight
no you can't
no
you're the one that said everything by
here
excuse me sir you can't volunteer my one
[Music]
how much you've been drinking
she hasn't figured it out yet
all right so isaac's 25 happy meal came
out
and you don't get a toy
i'm just playing you're two you're too
old for a cabinet how did it taste
i'm
yeah i got some cookies
you might actually be enjoying this
because i'm not a big fan i'm gonna try
it take a small bite and hopefully on
fingers crossed you don't like it and
i'll take the rest of it all right
toro
uni giant clam yellow that's a yellow
tail
just wow yeah wow because i only have
one piece yep oh that's toro that's
that's cooked
oh my god you're trying things that i've
never even imagined was possible cooked
toro who does that pregnant ladies
all right so i just had the first bite
of the uni yeah it's delicious so you're
out
this came in my plate so he wants to eat
it nice
what's it taste like
[Music]
it tastes like a mistake
it's like turtle skin or something
turtle i've never had turtles it's like
a bride you're a rock look at that
turtle turtle
meat oh man it's kind of weird i'm
starting to feel weird don't think too
much about it
i'm gonna do it
i'm good
[Music]
protein butter
there you go son had a boy
one of the favorite developments right
now in my life is seeing tiff become
a full-blown mom she's really welcoming
the idea of becoming a stay-at-home mom
and that means she's learning to cook i
made these noodles
malaysian hawker
noodles or something
you're the wife
i've always dreamt of my dreams and we
we both had to grow into the partners we
wanted yeah see the first time i eat
that's the first time
chinese food true it might be the first
time you guys eat uh chips cooking
i can't take all the credit
it's a meal good delivery thing but i
made it you get inspired by the baby
that's it
there's something about having a mom in
the house that cooks that just makes
home way more homey ever since she's
gotten pregnant she's been adamant about
learning to cook and she's been very
persistent about cooking almost every
night right now and i have to handle her
she's actually a really really good cook
but yeah it's just like an amazing
journey that i'm witnessing her do and i
get to enjoy the perks of it like the
cornbread she made on
[Music]
came thanksgiving so good
smell good too
airfryer cornbread
[Music]
she also made some pumpkin pie
cauliflower mashed potatoes and on the
other hand i smoked a prime rib roast
and two ducks and that was our
thanksgiving recap
[Music]
you